watch out for your limiting personal
beliefs because of story that you're
telling yourself is holding you back
it's keeping you as being the person
that you are instead of letting you
become the person that you can be last
week I had to go get a haircut I was
getting a little shaggy up here I
thought I got to do some videos I want
to look good need my new haircut so I
called up Romano who's my barber my
barber for maybe five years Italian guy
in his 50 60 s big mustache and I
decided to go see him and take my best
bout gorgeous sunny day here in Toronto
perfect day for a ride I hop on pull up
in front of his store he sees me on the
best when he comes out and he says I
used to ride a Vespa in Italy and you
can tell by looking at you know looking
into his eyes that he really missed
those days I said Romano why don't you
just get one no it's a gorgeous summer
go out and buy one for yourself he said
no I'm too old I'm too old to do it and
reminded me of when I was starting my
first business I was 19 and I was
selling the guys who were two or three
times my age and I told myself I'm too
young should do something else and I
eventually got over that fear and I
started selling and realized it was just
in my head these guys didn't care about
my age and so I told Romano Romano this
is just in your head you're not too old
to get on a vest but put around it's not
it's not you know gonna injure yourself
you could do it you're still able body
guy you can go out and ride it and I
told him why don't you take mine first
spin just take it around the block now
as soon as I said that I panicked a
little inside because I didn't want him
to drop my bike what he said no he said
not now and I saw something in Romano d
that he didn't see in himself
I knew he could do it but he didn't
think he can and the same thing applies
to all of us it applies to you other
people see things in you that you don't
see in yourself they see greatness that
you can't see because you're telling
yourself a story that's chock full of
living and personal beliefs whether you
think you can you can't you're right and
the only thing holding you back is a
story you keep telling yourself so
change your story good luck
you